[Music]
all right looking towards November
midterm momentum by Republicans is
growing by the day as trump-backed
candidates in States all across the
country now running winning campaigns
and pursuing an agenda to deliver
prosperity for their constituents for
example Republican Governors are now
leading the way in school reopenings job
growth business Prosperity working class
success all while Democrats double down
on you know more climate change alarmism
and of course higher taxes and greater
inflation higher energy costs anyway uh
one person that kind of wrote the road
map with great success is now Virginia
governor Glenn youngin is with us
Governor good to have you back how are
you
I'm doing great Sean thank you for
having me and you hit it right on the
nose I mean what we've seen across the
nation is just like Virginia last year
Americans standing up and saying wait a
minute open borders in a ruined economy
and oh by the way bureaucrats standing
between parents and their children and
defunding and demeaning police that's no
way forward and in Virginia last year
Republicans Independents and Democrats
came together and voted for Change and
we're about to do the same thing across
this entire country this year you know
you were able to bring something to the
Forefront in your campaign that I think
if people will pay attention to there
are the obvious issues record high
inflation a 40-year high record high gas
prices obvious you mentioned the borders
chaos at the borders uh but then you
brought into play education and teach
and and how we teach our kids and what
we're teaching our kids and the
age-appropriateness of what we should be
teaching our kids and you've made a lot
of moves as governor in that area and
the other area that that you've done a
lot of work on is Law and Order and
Safety and Security Governor I don't
think you can pursue happiness in
America if you're not safe and secure in
your town or city
you know Sean you're 100 right I mean
right out of the box we put into action
11 executive directors and we've
submitted 59 bills and our day one
agenda got moving and we in fact saw
that when we invest in law enforcement
as opposed to deplete resources when we
stand up for training and equipment and
we prosecute people guess what we can
combat Rising crime in Virginia we back
the blue and in education it was just
very straightforward lowering standards
is no way to have increasing results and
so we have a record education budget
this year we're investing in choice
we're investing yes in teachers and
Facilities but we also are going to
teach our children how to think and stop
teaching them what to think and it was
really important right out of the box
that we re-empowered parents we gave
them the ability to make decisions about
whether their child wears a mask or not
we gave them the ability to decide
whether the materials and the curriculum
or ones that fit their values not the
bureaucrats and the politician values
but family values these are basic basic
principles that Americans are going to
stand up for you know the the red wave
that started in Virginia is going to
Crest across this nation and come
crashing down on California governor I
want to cross your record you you've not
been in office very long we see Joe
Biden's policies what they've done to
destroy the economy in 18 short months
but just in a little over six months as
Governor you have given the Commonwealth
of Virginia four billion dollars in tax
relief the largest tax relief if I
understand it in Virginia history
including eliminating a state grocery
tax you doubled the standard deduction
for joint filers to sixteen thousand
dollars he gave every Virginia taxpayer
rebate on education uh I was shocked
you're spending more than uh ever spent
before in the history of the
Commonwealth 3.2 billion in direct Aid
and you increase Teachers Pay by 10
percent and I would think they might
like you for that you've also invested
in law enforcement 45 million of fund
school resource officers and and other
monies for law enforcement and the
results have been pretty impressive in
terms of job creation and what you've
been able to do for the economy and
what's happening in your school system
um that only that sounds like you've
taken your rhetoric campaign promises
and turned it into action which I
thought was also a signature of Donald
Trump
well Sean thank you and what happened on
day one is common sense prevailed and
it's an extraordinary thing when you all
of a sudden start laying out Common
Sense conservative solutions to problems
that face all Virginians and what we
recognize that of the box was even
though we don't have control of our
Senate because the Democrats have a
majority in our Senate we could always
use common sense and get somebody to
come with us this is about bringing
people together and delivering results
this is what voters want they're tired
of being told that someone else knows
better let's get around the kitchen
tables as Republicans this is what we're
seeing Republican Governors and
Republican Republican gubernatorial
candidates
right now is listen to voters and
they're going to win
let me ask you then because we've got an
important midterm election in November
and we got gubernatorial races we got
Senate candidates we got every House
member up for election what advice would
you give them what did you learn in your
race that they could apply to their
races that would help them in terms of
explaining what the agenda is that
they're standing for the promises
they're going to make and then of course
on the other side of it the importance
of keeping those promises
yeah well first Sean it is to in fact
campaign everywhere you know it's not
just Republicans we want independence
and we want a bunch of Democrats because
these Common Sense these Common Sense
conservative solutions to Everyday
challenges or what voters are worried
about you know the the left liberal
progressives want to tell everybody that
they should worry about things that
don't impact their lives the reality is
inflation school jobs crime and oh by
the way a government that's been telling
them what to do all the time as opposed
to working for them this is what voters
want so stay focused on those key
kitchen table issues deliver Solutions
and we're going to win across the
country just like we did last year in
Virginia and for those that don't know I
mean you went up uh against a seasoned
Pro and Terry McAuliffe not a
lightweight and you beat him handily in
a state that had been trending blue for
a long time anyway Governor appreciate
you being with us as always thank you
sir hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else